earth is really special in some way we
don't exactly know
the level of specialness we don't really
know which steps were the hardest or not
because we just have a sample of one
but you're saying that there's three to
12 steps that we have to go through to
get to where we are that are hard steps
hard to find by something that
took
uh a long time and is unlikely there's a
lot of
there's a lot of ways to fail there's a
lot more ways to fail than to succeed
the first step would be sort of the very
simplest form of life of any sort
and then um we don't know whether that
first sword is the first sort that we
see in the historical record or not
but then some other steps are say the
development of photosynthesis
the development of sexual reproduction
there's the development of eukaryote
cells which are certain kind of
complicated cell that seems to have only
appeared once
and then there's multicellularity that
is multiple cells coming together to
large organisms like us
and
in this statistical model of trying to
fit all these steps into a finite window
the model actually predicts that these
steps could be a varying difficulties
that is they could each take different
amounts of time on average but
if you're lucky enough that they all
appear in a very short time then the
durations between them will be roughly
equal
and the time remaining left over in the
rest of the window will also be the same
length so
we at the moment have roughly a billion
years left on earth until
simple life like us would no longer be
possible
life appeared roughly 400 million years
after the very first time when life was
possible at the very beginning
so those two numbers right there give
you the rough estimate of six hard steps
just to build up an intuition here so
we're trying to create a simple
mathematical model
of how life emerges and expands in the
universe
and uh there's a section in this paper
how many hard steps question mark right
uh the two most plausibly diagnostic
earth durations seem to be the one
remaining after now before earth becomes
uninhabitable for complex life so you
estimate how long earth lasts
how many hard steps
there's windows
for doing different hard steps and you
can sort of like cueing theory
mathematically estimate of
like
uh the uh solution or the passing of the
hard steps or the taking of the hard
steps sort of like coldly mathematical
look
if life
pre-expansionary life requires a number
of steps what is the probability of
taking those steps on an earth that
lasts a billion years or 2 billion years
or 5 billion years or 10 billion years
and you say
solving for e using the observed
durations of 1.1 and 0.4 then gives e
values of 3.9 and 12.5 range 5.7 to 26
suggesting a middle estimate of at least
six that's where you said six
hard steps right
just to get to where we are right we
started at the bottom now we're here and
that took six steps on average the key
point is
on average these things on any one
random planet would take you know
trillions or trillions of trill you know
of years just a really long time and so
we're really lucky that they all
happened really fast in a short time
before our window closed
and the chance of that happening
in that short window goes as that time
period to the power of the number of
steps and so that was where the power we
talked about before it came from
and so
that means in the history of the
universe we should overall roughly
expect advanced life to appear as a
power law in time
so that very early on there was very
little chance of anything appearing and
then later on as things appear other
things are appearing somewhat closer to
them in time because they're all going
as this power law
what is the power law can we for people
who are not sure math inclined can you
describe what a power so
say the function x is linear and x
squared is quadratic so it's the power
of two if we make x to the three that's
cubic or the power of three and so x to
the sixth is the power of six
and so we'd say
life appears in the universe on a planet
like earth in that proportion to the
time that it's been
you know
uh ready for life
to appear
and that
over the universe in general it'll
appear at roughly a power law like that
what is the exponent what is n
uh is it the number of hearts yes the
number of hard steps so that's so yeah
it's like if you're gambling
and you're doubling up every time this
is the probability you just keep winning
[Laughter]
so
it gets very unlikely very quickly and
so we are the result of this unlikely
chain of successes it's actually a lot
like cancer so the dominant model of
cancer in an organism like each of us is
that we have all these cells and in
order to become cancerous a single cell
has to go through a number of mutations
and these are very unlikely mutations
and so any one cell is very unlikely to
have any have all these mutations happen
by the time your life spans over
but
we have enough cells in our body that
the chance of any one cell producing
cancer by the end of your life is
actually pretty high more like 40
percent
and so the chance of cancer appearing in
your lifetime also goes as power law
this power of the number of mutations
that's required for any one cell in your
body to become cancerous this is the
longer you live the likely right you are
to have cancer cells and the power is
also roughly six that is
the chance of you getting cancer is at
the roughly the power of six of the
time you've been since you were born it
is perhaps not lost
on people that you're
that you're comparing the power laws of
the survival or the arrival of the human
species to cancerous cells
the same mathematical model but of
course we might have a different value
assumption about the two outcomes but of
course from the point of view of
cancer somewhere similar uh from the
point of view of cancer it's a win-win
well we both get to
we both get to thrive i suppose
you